hello everybody and welcome to part 5 of
let's play from dust alright as we left
off we just built up this new village
here um that'll be the third village I
don't think it gave me a power but I'm
guessing this rock it's gonna give me
some power so I gotta figure out a way
to get over there I'm pretty sure it has
to do with Gela fiying the water problem
is the timing because when they go over
there but I don't time it right they'll
get stuck and just flip out on me
screaming for help and then drowning in
the river so I'm trying to avoid that
all right come on come on guess not you
why you of all people going there I say
no oh my goodness I hate you so much
you're stuck on that rock anyway what
that what the f up now you know you're
gonna die they're gonna die there we go
finally finally Oh take your umbrella
and go you're going that way of all the
directions that seemed the best to you
whatever but oh there we go finally you
got some brains on you let me just
jellify the water for you oh you're
welcome you are welcome madam with your
nice kite go go my little minion go
climb that rock go go go yay yay all
right make it make it dots the lava
oh you so great yes
uh what well now what's the problem
really that's it that's what blocking
you Oh fine fine
gosh lucky I got like 30 seconds left on
this jellify water deal don't know how
I'm doing that by the way oh you gotta
be kidding me
get-get oh don't give me that don't sass
me girl not all you did come on how do I
pick you up can I wash you down there oh
don't make me tell maybe this gel what
it'll drown you in a second
Oh got to light there you go deal with
that get washed
oh hey you hate you Oh fine I'm gonna
build so much sand you're just gonna
make it there it's just gonna that's
just how it's gonna be there still got a
problem oh come on not now oh okay that
okay that was a bet that was a fluke not
your fault I don't blame you for that
okay there we go they're wet do your
thing Oh
shaking okay don't have a seizure
there we go okay you got whatever it was
that did it apparently all right make it
through there all you're gonna need my
help again I just got a dam this whole
thing up maybe maybe whoa something's
happening whoa
that is probably a bad idea to set up
camp next to a active volcano Oh perfect
perfect Oh mark you are so smart you are
you are indeed oh come on
how's it flowing back in fine fine I
will isolate you from everything you
will be the most sheltered of my minions
there and I'll even be nice enough to
take the water out there you go you
happy now
are you so needy but are you my
girlfriend ha ha ha oh I don't have a
girlfriend
oh oh right ok moving on not that I
can't get a girlfriend I just don't have
one right now yeah that's it it's
totally it that sounds like screaming
for help people dying
what's going on what's going on
okay oh no not you old lady
there you okay now what did that do
oh okay uh cool whatever that did play
music I guess that's pretty cool music
is important to our everyday lives
as are all of the arts let me see how
high I can dam up this water I'd really
like to see hello give me that lava
whoa-ho that went way down in there no
more mark mark mark mark waters helping
cuz it's instantly cooling it
come on Oh Who am i drowning now ah no
the surge of water is coming ah come on
come on come on oh yeah
I'm so great I know I know I'm well
aware that this is a fruitless endeavor
however I am enjoying myself if you all
don't like it well I'm sorry about that
I really am but there's nothing I can do
with that okay the only logical next
step if I go to the next level
oh I've totally [ __ ] myself over
haven't I oh [ __ ] me oh god damn it
ah no what have I done
I'm such a horrible person alright
anyway I can deal with this um how can I
deal with this Oh poop up girl
okay all right I can figure out a way
okay I'm gonna divert the water I've
channeled all the water down one
direction that's not a good thing okay
just gonna lock this up so it goes a
different way
more different direction gimme lava okay
now that's kind of going the other way
that's partly helping then I just have
to deal with this and I can jellify that
okay still good I don't have to restart
alright let's get my guys over there go
go minions go whoa what what what's
happening
oh my get the water not the sand get the
water oh my god Oh what did I do that I
didn't do that do I do that
oh my goodness oh oh oh oh oh
everyone's dead oh no oh no everyone oh
oh no I lost everybody ah get away get
away get away
Oh f-you oh man I'm sorry about that I
should have been paying more attention
than playing with the lava alright I'll
get you I got you here we go alright
there we go all done all done there all
you need to cross okay I'm not the sand
water there we go
you best believe in me now I'm pretty
sure I did this to the entire ocean all
across the world so I am pretty powerful
amazingly so alright the man at poor
village all of them dead I got to build
something up to try to stop that from
happening
no not again not again oh not again not
again not again not again Oh more lavas
not gonna hell mark what am i doing what
am i doing oh no no I can't get get get
no it's still jelly oh no I'm so sorry
ah no oh sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
ah this isn't really my fault but I'm
still sorry I'm responsible for your
well-being I've replaced your burning to
death with drowning to death oh no oh oh
good gracious gravy Oh No
oh my word oh oh I'm Elise Dickens oh
man oh oh oh sorry sorry
oh wow I just got to move on oh but if I
move on like these are these people are
still gonna be dying
technically oh maybe I could just figure
out a way to divert it oh I see what
it's doing it's like constantly
depositing more earth oh no oh oh you
are persistent people but you really
should stop building there
I'm just saying oh wow that's that makes
me feel bad
yeah village destroyed again Oh oh boy I
gotta get out of here I got I feel bad
and this is I could do oh so sorry
telomere sarcasm Annie yup Oh Madame et
de l'école Ubu okay zip it America y'all
Aggie Lee sounds good way
oh you surviving members sorry about
your cousins and family
all right moving on moving away from the
horrifying tragedy that befell them
under my watch it will not happen again
here I promise you people that who the
thousand sources to see my Siberia ah la
mundo coup de la barra de una mara
ah ha no collage add America energy oh
not much water I saw it you bad human
October come oh boy
something Bad's happening here I can
tell by the spiny thorns all right let's
see lots and lots of desert there's the
next portal my guys are all here they
need to go there ish so let's get them
there start sanding up the place alright
I don't want it to go that way sucks Dan
that up so all goes the other way
Oh deal with it deal with it big whoop
your whole village was burning to death
and you're complaining about a little
sand just get out of there okay
get out of there there we go a little
more all right there we go
man it is arid hey I are are ejd arid
that's that sounds about right
oh I see they're like Springs oh wow
cool oh no bad oh man if I dig up sand
in the wrong places these are just gonna
pop up there whenever I can cover them
up boom yep gone that's actually pretty
cool okay so they're controllable if I
dig out Moore's all right yeah become
bigger and if I cover it up gone just
like that you two gone okay all right up
no I have to cut it here thank you guys
so much for watching I appreciate it I
will see you guys in part 6 of let's
play from dust bye bye